effectivement le prix du médicament est
dans notre pays et tout à fait important
nous avons choisi
les gouvernements de gauche et de droite
de considérer le prix du médicament
comme le variable d'ajustement dans les
comptes de la Sécurité sociale pour
diminuer les dépenses
on est abouti on a abouti ainsi à ce que
actuellement je parle en grande masse
50% des spécialités pharmaceutiques
françaises
sont les moins chers du marché européen
et que 92% des spécialités
pharmaceutiques françaises
ont un prix inférieur au prix moyen des
5 grands pays européens la France
l'Allemagne le Royaume-Uni l'Espagne et
l'Italie qui constituent le gros du
marché pharmaceutique
ce n'est pas sans inconvénient puisque
évidemment les détenteurs de stock de
ces produits peuvent à tout moment être
tentés de les distribuer dans des pays
qui ont
appris de vente plus intéressants comme
par exemple l'exemple de l'amoxicilline
dont la forme injectable est à peu près
deux fois plus cher en Allemagne qu'en
France
et ce marché parallèle donc vous avez
certainement entendu les différents
des différents acteurs c'est quand même
5 milliards de chiffre d'affaires
donc
on a choisi une politique d'écrasement
des prix dont on peut penser qu'elle
n'est pas sans impact sur les
approvisionnements même si ce n'est pas
sans doute l'aspect principal des des
ruptures que nous enregistrons